[Musique]
c'est très simple d'avoir deux équipes
que juste répondre à des questions de
culture youtube viennent pour trouver
crié un taulier quoi donc j'espère vous
ai réalisé un petit peu bonjour et
bienvenue sur le quiz youtube
c'est du coup le grand quizz pour tester
la culture youtube des candidats qui
sont autour de la table
vous pouvez aussi jouer chez vous c'est
autorisé il y a quand même un très grand
trophée à gagner qui est juste ici le
trophée du grand gagnant du prix youtube
à gauche c'est le gameplay button et je
sais je garde
à ma gauche nous avons squeeze nous
avons le grand j d bonjour merci qui
viennent directement de suisse vous
serez la team jamie à ma droite nous
avons seb la frite
bonjour merci mais non merci d'être là
et héma-québec up est exactement quel
mac et coop qui a poussé très complexe
et compliqué à dire je te vous serez la
team kitty voilà ça c'est un atout et
jenny dulys glissait le chien propos
qu'on connaît c'est fini voilà il gagne
déjà un point c'est tout alors on va
commencer avec ce qu'on appelle le pré
roll ça va être des petites hussein
tim kitty est ce que vous êtes prêts
attention première question quel
youtuber n'existe pas mais d'où il fait
l'andouille
mais elle fait le fifo momo le déglingo
outils mais au fait le zouave zouaves
wav c'est impossible a déjà possible
mais louis bélanger quand même nom mais
mais d'où il fait 9 h et 3 contres qui
existe il n'ya pas forcément dvd vidéo
surtout donc les consommateurs qui les a
créés bah non j'ai rien vu que c'est des
gens très spontanée elle a ainsi inventé
moi je parte 72 points vous êtes prêts
tim johnny n'est ce pas sur youtube vous
ne trouverez pas le challenge suivant
essaye de ne pas bander essaye de ne pas
lâcher un pouce bleus essaye de ne pas
chanter essaye de ne pas faire caca ça
soit j'ai vu que j'avais j'ai vu tu
avais je la hais une lutte à vue les
trois il me semble que c'est le début a
tenté pas c'est que j'ai vu à et me
semble me semble donc je pense que c'est
un mois c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est mon
avis et ça je te prends un abattoir une
question essaye de ne pas bondée on a
déjà essayé de ne pas lâcher ils sont
d'accord
essayez de j'ai déjà vu non je suis pas
sur cela je suis pas sûre et essaye de
ne pas chanter s'agit déjà vu donc c'est
à mon ami la fin 50 50 c'est bien à mon
avis et c'est de ne pas faire caca et
quand on parle de kaka j'ai fait l'homme
kaka jeu vidéo jamais allez vas-y
barrère kkc essaye de ne pas lâcher un
pouce bleus c'est un modèle que titi
n'est ce pas quelle expérience sociale
ibra tv n'a jamais fait faire croire
qu'ils piègent un pédophile faire croire
que les clowns tueur existe faire croire
qu'ils sauvent un chien des flammes
faire croire qu'ils sauvent un racket
franchement je crois que je sais non les
crimes il l'a fait il a fait moi je sais
ap deux films je sais qu'il l'avait fait
j'ai vu la vidéo au pouvoir c'est le
chien dans les flammes papa officiel il
faut qu'il ya déjà dans syndicaux fin
d'un championnat je crois que je pense
moi qui se fascise telle expérience
sociale ibra tv n'a jamais fait il n'a
jamais fait croire qu'ils sauvent un
chien des flammes bien jouer c'est un
passé pas toujours d'ici à mai la
réponse est non pas tim gelli laquelle
de ces story times n'existe pas encore
il ya un complot j'ai couché avec le
copain de ma pote ma pote a couché avec
mon copain j'ai pas garder ma soeur ou
master mans poignardé c'est une
perdition qu un même si on procède par
élimination le reste de l a3 qui existe
un rappel à s'espacer toi qui es cochon
j'ai aucune idée
honnêtement je suis alors non là j'ai
couché avec le copain de la pote ça je
pense que c'est possible oui mais ma
pote a couché avec mon copain retrouve
ses plus beaux de ma pote a couché avec
mon copain que j'ai couché avec le
copain de ma pote
pourquoi je sais pas comment c'est
si tu interview j'ai regardé ma certains
sdf c'est pourquoi il est là les gens
les oreilles de votre projet en fait
remixer qui doit alors si c'est sûr
qu'il est mon pauvre qui s'est passé
l'instance est plus massa va pas garder
vas-y non non moi j'ai choisi un bon
j'étais sur le cac à l'investisseur le
point et c'est un point enfin c'est
facile facile on en est arrivé à la fin
du pré roll
du coup interdit non non attendez c'est
la 1ère manche 1 pour 1 ch et 1.6
espaces non non on va enchaîner sur une
épreuve de rapidité
d'accord d'accord ça va parler
essentiellement de youtuber francophones
ça s'appelle can you tube jeudi
l'intitulé est parfois la vie péan
premier me donner la réponse qu'elle
youtuber était policier a tous un point
la ville -tenu la question quel youtuber
a sorti un film sur lui remy r oui
officielle à l'avant par les commandes
des tubes heures à fait secretistes
louis billon bruchon web et youtube
heures a fait une vidéo sur son contrôle
fiscal notre faut oser gones je vais
contrôler
passons donc au nom des personnes très
mignon et ben c'était si fano avec une
vidéo qui s'appelle on contrôle fiscal
attention quel tube e rapidité can you
tube heures un diamond club automne oui
bien sûr pardon on y retourne à quel
youtuber a fait une vidéo pour l'armée
attention bien sûr l'occasion pendant
dix ans je sais que un dernier attention
et rapidité souples est qu'elles
youtuber appelait j'ai plusieurs idées
américaines même un plan de portis faire
maintenant c'est une remontée
fantastique un de tianjin
qu'est-ce qui se passe je crois que un
squeeze nous a dit wade au début et je
crois que l'effort est en fait c'est lui
qui fait recette
il est vraiment plus tard précaire on va
arriver à la dernière manche avant la
finale ckoi l'espoir 6 à 3 pour vous tu
voulais juste te dire que tu étais pas
c'est un qcm basé sur des miniatures
s'appelle le put à cliquer dans cette
manche de deux points gagnés pour chaque
aperçu par clic trouve et quel est le
titre de cette vidéo
ok c'est senna s'est du coup cette vidéo
qui est vraiment story times amoureux en
temps de guerre
comment on fait rencontrer le jour où
tout a basculé on intègre les forces
spéciales
bonne chance moi je le jure il embrasse
je me dis non c'est trop non mais non
mais alors la miniature c'est pas trop
tôt les gens et toi tu t'en fous qui est
d'aider floyd sait même pas comment
débattre chevaux qui bat déjà on peut
enlever le jour si c'est ça moi je dirai
comment ces rencontres et je sais pas je
différents pôles ou à une histoire un
footing et ses deux points qui
séparaient team n'est ce pas jelly alors
quel est le titre de cet aperçu
dégustations à l aveugle qui tourne mal
touche mon corps challenge vous
devinerez jamais ce que j'ai touché je
ne contrôle plus ma main il est suisse
le type 1 il faut comme le précise et
ouais tu connais tu vois là oui il
existe c'est mon frère
après l'ag jamais vu cio
donc voila moi il ya une mode aux us
c'est le tu dois faire deviner une
partie de ton corps l'autre me louis oui
on est là dessus on aime on a envie de
dire touch ou encore chanel errements
d'un bus station avec qui tourne mal je
comprends pas comment il a pu se passer
dernier clément darbo boya qui touche un
singe magot il a fait notre force et
faut vous n'aurez jamais ce que j'ai
touché c'est quand même un peu drôle je
pense pas qu'ils aillent là c'est dans
ce livre vers ça et je ne contrôle plus
ma main bonjour je suis mon camp
caennais je pense que c'est ça parce que
c'est typiquement le genre à faire des
embrouilles à l'auvent rouge à preuve le
moins de 18 touches leur ménage etc
râteau et tu vois et je pense que ça va
on est d'accord on est d'accord c'est
deux points pour moi
il faut il faut rester à quai en raison
game attention sur cet aperçu là sur
cette miniature il me trompe je me venge
ça tourne mal
ma copine a perdu ça mon cap shaw cole
je me suicide pour la faire rager petit
ami mort challenge petit ami mort tu
attends si c'est vraiment elle genre 6c
je me venge et qu'elle est morte et mets
pas ça sur youtube
moi je pense que je me suicide pour le
faire rager non je peux d'accord t'es
pas d'accord
la copine a perdu c'est mon club ça vous
a nommé 13 fois c'est génial moi c'est
le seul titre vous aurez cliqué
jean-victor pas confiance mais si c'est
pas ça je serais très déçu
la menace majesté va là j'ai un énorme
doute une foule de tous qu'est ce qu'on
fait jean pierre feuille ciseaux pierre
feuille ciseaux et voilà ça dégage petit
ami morte petit ami maps challenge zinc
exprimés par ces deux points
à l'encontre d'un aperçu vous pouvez
gagner encore deux points attention sur
cet aperçu lacets je montre ma à des
inconnus faire caca dans la rue
challenge bagarre à cause d'un prix au
cas où draguer des meufs en couple
fourneaux mal moi je reviens sur le cac
à sa carrière serait pas allé
l'embrouillé il aurait six qui visent au
fmi si c'est ce mec t'as raison c'est je
monte ma quête à des inconnus pas du
tout que draguer des meufs en couple
tournoi commence à me tourner mal au
point que ce soit pour elle ces mecs je
vais déjà dit on ne juge pas ici
effectivement il se retrouver à poil et
s'est dit draguer des meufs en couple
entre parenthèses tournon mal c'est le
titre adéquat à cette vidéo nous avons
des grands gagnants ici c'est la team
djelic on peut applaudir bravo bah oui
désolé ça vous a plu
ouais je suis rendu compte que j'étais
très nul vraiment je sais qu'ils ont
commencé sur moi aussi je me suis rendu
compte que qu'elle était très nul je
propose que tu as les deux les deux
gagnants mon tour vous allez changer de
si peu de place s'il vous plaît pas
dernière manche
rester du côté gagnant exprès à part ça
je fais alors qui va gagner ce fameux
trophée du youtube
il va falloir répondre à un maximum de
bonnes questions en une minute qui va
commencer
alors je commence tu commandes en 2d ce
conteur la drogue passages jugés adroits
dire je passe bien sûr tu peux passer et
vous il faut répondre à la question ou
terminale phrase d'accord ok très bien
top tic est le premier film avec norman
paranormal activity quel collectif a
écrit et réalisé les dissocier [ __ ] je
suis stressée je passe je l'avais vu les
combien de what the cut to the past
prenez le temps de regarder mes vidéos
jeux les locaux sont les cent plus gros
youtuber de france 13 % sont des femmes
faux where you tube heures qui vient de
grenoble mr oui évidemment en quelle
année a été créée youtube en france où
dominent
en france en 2000 2005 2004 2005
combien d'abonnés pour recevoir leur
diplôme l'automne ah oui oui 10 millions
marion jeux flash a été rendu culte
partie dubaï
je passe nous vient kamini de marigot
une vidéo on déballe les vêtements qu'on
a acheté ça s'appelle j'étais trop
stressée pour l'applaudir à tout cas
dans la tête norman pas trainer maximum
qui arrive et me soucier
je suis rich iott mais je l'avais
revêche de benoît de 4,37 n'avait pas
besoin chez l'ado prenez le temps d'y
penser
pardon on passe désormais à jean-michel
cerise et qui va devoir faire mieux j'ai
ouï dire que hélas son petit niveau sur
jamais fait gaffe parce que tu as toutes
les idées tattoo séparation est prêt
vas-y je suis prêt top
comment s'appelle le livre donne à tous
icône oui au début de youtube ont noté
les vidéos avec des étoiles vrai ou faux
un vrai oui c'est en faisant n'importe
quoi qu'on devient n'importe qui ratchet
& clank le film doublé par squeeze a
fait plus de 200 maisons très vrai ou
faux ça s'appelle le jeu de poisson fait
qu'on fût ce cadre c'est de la bombe
le gimmick de norman c'est vrai ou faux
le guennic de norman youtube heure belge
dumoulin il était possible de jouer au
snack sur une vidéo youtube bref type
mois une convention de vidéastes
d'internet vidéo ch'ti pendant un moment
le compteur de vue se bloquaient
toujours à 299,99 passant une merde
un des premiers clashs connu sur youtube
c'est moi et comme ce texte qu'elle est
aux premiers vulgarisateur français à
avoir passé la barre du million
d'abonnés
je passe chez youtube heures américain
était la star du délit vlog et l'arrêté
casey et les stats
oui de youtube heures qui s'appelle
nouveau une composée boycott ouais c'est
tellement incroyable égalisateur c'est
vraiment qu'ils aient un toit
eh ben je pense qu'on a notre grand
gagnant emploi oui j'ai le prix de
poésie youtube ouais c'est beaucoup jp
merci les gars ont du plaisir
rappel vous avez tout perdu c'est plus
qu'un merci d'avoir suivi sa d'art votre
écran j'espère que ça vous a plu il va y
avoir d'autres crises à venir le saviez
vous n'hésitez pas à vous abonner aux
chaînes des jonctions là si vous
connaissez des gens qui ont derrière eux
aussi donné à tout le monde
abonnez vous à toutes les personnes que
vous croisez dans la rue
un pouce en l'air ce genre de choses
qu'on dit très régulièrement sur tous
les réseaux sociaux du genre copains
d'avant
à bientôt c'est super marrant
nos adversaires ont été carrément à la
hauteur si très cool précéderont le
cidre ou les questions étaient hyper
marrant tu es bon les super bowl s'est
pour une fois je gagnais un jour et ce à
sa merci
[Musique]